hi everyone good morning my name is kaya
I'm going to be talking about a very
fundamental concept in thermodynamics
but before I start have you all done
planes before yeah okay I mean wonder
how does the pilot land the plane later
alright so I'm gonna split two concepts
that help you understand how we actually
land the plane and these two concepts
are the concepts of finished and angle
of attack so it'll make it picture plane
going through the sky and in real life
the planes though don't fly perfectly
horizontal they actually play it animal
and be sango between the horizontal and
the plane is going to be known as alpha
the animal attack and these values
usually about 10 degrees so that's why
it seems that there's going uphill when
you walk up a person plane now there are
two forces acting on the plane you're
gonna have gravity and weight they'll be
clean pulling the weight down and you're
going to also have a force upwards
that's keeping the cleanest load and
that force is called lift which we're
going to denote by L lift is generated
as saira brushes through the wings the
wings are designed in such a way that
there goes through them they're gonna
generate a force upwards so that's what
keeps the planet float
now there's the relationship between
lift and the angle of attack and then I
was training the following plot so we're
going to have on the x-axis I'm going to
have the
in degrees and then the y-axis I'm gonna
have to live which is the pulse and
there has to be some humans now it is
known that it's small and also attack
the if you increase the angle of attack
a little bit you're gonna get more of it
so if you force a little more so you're
going to get an upward strength in the
first part of the club
now you might even you have a very high
angle of attack that the place won't
actually really see the flow is going to
be quite a diverse to the wings so
they're going to stop generating lift so
if you make the angle even steeper
you're going to get even a VESA lift so
that means thinning these part of the
plot at very high angles of attack
you're going to get even less even less
lift as you increase the angle yes
there's a question by extreme angles to
me like greater than 45 degrees or
greater than 15 actually so you have
history genes and there's a smooth
transition in between and the the
maximum occurs at 15 degrees and this
condition at which the thing starts to
lose lift is known as a stall so when
the nerd thing starts to loose with its
stalls
now airplanes usually play about 10
degrees you want the angle of attack to
be high so if you get a lot of lift but
not so high that you will stall so to
land the plane what does the pattern
should we do he approaches the wrong way
at 10 degrees to normal angle and when
he's about to hit the ground he changes
the angle of attack to 15 degrees and
stalls so big looks a lot of lift and
they actually crash the plane gently to
the ground all right
are there any questions yes to the
aerodynamics of a plane affect the stop
point they do in the sole point depends
on the velocity of the plane which
planes going at at the shape of the
wings but it's usually around 15 degrees
for any sort of claim there are place
the ones were that actually can play
vertical those ones have other sorts of
control they're stalling the wings are
stalling but they have fancy motors that
can hold that angle there were there was
another question it's the question
sorry could you be any louder please
you're in it I believe also the angle
with respect to the plane yes yes so the
question you see if the wings have an
angle with respect to the plane and yes
they do the plane moves something like
nation G Queen serve at some level of
two to three degrees respectively so
it's a nice everybody's a smiling but
then the cross-section actually changes
and you look at the everything from the
front but we're actually doing something
like this so there's similar of angles
going on
you